[Music]
what is everypony its goals at an anti
here for anime uproar yeah and after 18
months we're finally getting to that Q&A
video that you guys have been waiting
for so yeah pumped for that we got a
whole bunch of awesome questions we've
got to print it out right here so we're
going to be reading them and answering
them for you guys and we're also going
to be showcasing some of your artwork
because a whole bunch of you guys send
us your fan art and other artwork so
while we're reading the questions you're
going to see the artwork on the screen
and you're going to be able to see the
Twitter accounts for those people or the
deviantART account you're going to see
the links in the description so be sure
to check that out we get a lot of
talented people here in our community
goes in again thank you guys so much for
over 10,000 K and so much for all of
your questions we couldn't get to all of
them but this definitely won't be the
last Q&A video first one coming from
2spooky events whoo congratulations and
cheers to many more would you rather be
a toaster or a waffle iron and why the
toaster is a four slicer and the waffle
iron has a compartment built-in for
syrup storage yeah I don't know about
the storage stuff
all I know is I don't want to be eaten
so I'd rather be the thing that doesn't
get eaten I don't think either than one
of the poster ones a iron waffle iron I
don't think either I don't get eaten
anyways not a cry that Jesse and
so I I'll go with the toaster because I
feel like the built-in syrup storage
would probably it's not hygienic
I feel like it what papi I know thank
you for this soft roll key question
2spooky and for a bonus question yes
what are your plans for future
milestones that's a good question yes so
for our 20000 subscribers we're going to
make a Q&A video at 30,000 us our plan
right now right golden yes and for a
million this guy is wearing a maid
outfit true 1 million subscribers I'm
dressing up and cosplaying as a maid so
let's make that happen guy yeah okay so
Allen aka Alex axe I have been wandering
for a while now what wasn't it may just
want to start making videos and what do
you think about all the shipping that
happens into this cord two completely
different questions about the shipping I
think in anime communities that is just
how things go shipping all over the
place shipping and handling in some
cases in terms of how we decide to start
making videos that make every give me at
this one so for this one as I always
like videography right I always like
filming stuff and I always do I wanted
to do something with video if I could
and I never thought it could be a job
but I thought it could be a passionate
they Iraq know they started making
ambe's or random videos on YouTube have
many different accounts and obviously
with anime stuff you usually get
copyrighted so a lot of those accounts
are closed now but anyways one time I
was creating a new account because I
have too many strikes on one and Anna
Mack actually helped me come up with the
name it's anime uproar okay and we
didn't think it would be as big as it is
now but a surplus some videos on there
and recently about a year ago we
actually started going hard and posting
regular bids and here we are today and
also for me it's mostly for the fangirls
I just wanted fangirls he's all that
fashion [ __ ] I just wanted the fangirls
guys with anime fan pan aka April asks
will to twitch be really active and yes
this month in May we're planning on
doing some stuff on Twitch together
goals and actually bought my girlfriend
controller and another
she thought though
jack-in-the-box games that are really
thought to play in groups all-night
party games so we're going to be you can
play with a bunch of people so we're
going to be playing those on Twitch
using this court to get you guys
informed about it and everything and
we're going to be playing stuff like
undertale brawlhalla hardened against
humanity hopefully with you guys if you
want to play with us so yeah in May
we're starting up the twitch stay tuned
for that you can follow us on Twitch
link in the description be sure to do
that now because that's going to be
crazy
otsuru asks first this one comes from
our good old friend all the anime brigs
Vegeta what does the scouter say about
his power level its over 9000 over 9000
grats my dudes 10k is a huge milestone
enjoy it and for the question
you guys find all seven dragonballs and
only have one wish what would it be oh
my god hard we talked about this with
our friends so many times oh dude oh you
know first ah why um I guess right now
probably not the best wish but I wish
that I had enough money to just do what
I want to do like this stuff and not
worry about finance and trying to
finance it right so I think having
enough money so I can do what I love
would be my main thing that's weak man
that week that's very shallow what I
would do is I would ask to get Geass
power Lelouch is gas power salt because
I only want to control the people I want
to control you know that's all I want I
don't necessarily want money
I just want power mad power guys Brent
from Brent fandoms asks I want to see
hashtag black Boris so that's not like
Anna Mac after dark is one thing black
Boris we don't talk about black Boris
okay Bryn we'll talk about it first
rolled back Boris we don't talk about
life exactly and she asks my question is
will we ever get to see Animax dark
alter-ego brought to light so she and
she said the answer is yes I pray and I
don't know I don't think you guys are
ready for black Boris and by the way
bread made us a lovely fan art for me
and goes on
you guys could see that on the screen
and you know what goals are actually
thinks that he looks better than me in
this one which is insanely crying the
way reflects reality in that sense good
job red so again continuing art in our
tradition of holy asking questions right
so here's Danny Van Melle Mel I came
here at first because of Code Geass and
I'm sure lot of you did and I'm learning
more about other anime and I love it
keep it up smiley face okay so thank you
bro we really appreciate it and that's
that's kind of over here for we're here
for Code Geass but all these other
awesome anime too right we got as anime
before Code Geass and we want to share
that with you and I love it that we can
show you anime you haven't seen and
truly come to appreciate it it's amazing
what he said so our boy and best rap on
that wolf Amelia asks what make you
realize you want it to be anime
youtubers and why the name anime out
drawer and what the anime used to report
we testified before but I just found
myself making videos when I was younger
and I loved it anime was a big passion
in my life and that's why we just it
just grew right and Anna Mack thought it
was a great idea we started making
videos and now it's become what it is
today and I can't wait to see where we
are like five years from now yeah and
basically what why we came up with anime
or is when we were looking for names who
were looking for something that no one
else was using so that we could have our
own you know unique twitch address
YouTube Twitter Gmail and basically we
wanted something that sounds cool
something that smells energetic
high-energy [ __ ] but also that no one
else was using and after a bunch of
trying googling stuff seeing is other
stuff like yeah we don't like anime
uproar yeah let's do it
and there's actually a lot of work
realizes so yeah don't great okay next
one comes from our boy in okis c2 best
light cool bro do you guys think that
c2x aloose is going to be Canada in r3
yes maybe a c2 and Lelouch child maybe
probably not but we'll see do you have
your hopes up we'll see you see two best
waifu am i right of course of course
you know he's gonna be like c2 best
waifu you know you're gonna say that
don't you
even though he knows were like Colin but
it's okay what is your guys favorite
anime mine is boku no pico obviously
okay I know goes no no judgment no
judgments but for me it's Clannad after
story it's no competition Code Geass
like Ana back away says it says top
three it's definitely my top three but
cloud after story is showed me like you
know beautiful epicness God you know
like it's just so good
it gave me a glimpse of God okay so I my
favorite anime is good and logon as
everyone knows because of a big calming
itard as they call me but yeah I just
felt good because it's so inspirational
it motivates me to be better to reject
what other people tell me it's possible
and impossible and so Korea is top 3 so
my top three are Gurren Lagann full
Mahatma's Brotherhood and Code Geass but
one fun fact about goes that you guys
didn't know he loves come after story so
much then when I learned to do karaoke
songs from cannot after story I used it
against it is his weakness
I just start singing that [ __ ] and he
starts crying and breaks down completely
and I win every argument
oh I cringe more than I cry next
question so flare asks Code Geass really
help your channel grow he says and he
asks did we start making Code Geass
video because we are true fans of Code
Geass or just because we saw that there
was a big fan base for it oh man why
don't I get to this okay so first of all
go back to our earliest videos not
surprising code as the first MV Clannad
but the next like four or five or Code
Geass videos and this was like three
years ago or more so clearly we're huge
Code Geass fans that's one of the first
things you have on this channel right
yeah and flash also asks what we do with
the channel once code yes is no longer
popular after the sequel airs and all
that kind of stuff and basically we're
still going to make code use videos when
we want to when we enjoy it and
obviously you still talk about all the
animes like Cowboy Bebop you know
there's no plan for a new sequel but we
still talk about it but as you can see
we have a lot of different content on
this channel yeah and you guys might
have noticed that every week
weekly news videos we have rant cafe
where we talk about all sorts of stuff
so what we want called yes we're going
to continue talking about it we love a
bunch of other anime as well and we're
going to always be talking about anime
about news all the latest cool stuff
because yeah it's fun and you love it
from crobat Gok we have a question can
you speak Serbian for us
Nana shunts name is something that's
been a feature masters computer name
Asante labora is that bloody tool push
me quit us but era business is happening
what's up Josh daphne asks what is the
funniest anime you have ever seen
mmm that's a good question and you know
what I'm gonna say to top my head it
comes to me School Rumble for the parts
that I seen some of the most
laugh-out-loud moments I've ever had the
ending I warned you for me wasn't good
it was [ __ ] but the actual anime was
hilarious and you know some people are
going to be like man and it was so real
man it was so real
man you just don't get it your handle
just don't you know for me as well
School Rumble was hilarious probably the
one most consistently hilarious anime
however there's a bunch of other ones I
can think of the devil is a part-timer
at hilarious moments my little monster
really funny and irritated me sometimes
I was funny yeah yeah so definitely a
lot of comedy anime I have to say we're
big fans but probably School Rumble is
one of both the first one we both think
of yeah so we'll give us a school rumble
on it Tony
black pretty guy this one's for you
Jalal fraud does asks the main question
are we occult what what is your tough
boy
we're not a cult bro we're not this is
old this is over this is over
Latika Latika asks and I call Allah
dicks by the way I called my Diggs what
made you collab with the mustache man
Mac alot and how did you meet
black Critic guy great questions great
questions and with Mac basically what
happened is we went to anime North 2016
and work on soon to finally yes this
month it's going to be all
but basically went to animate north and
it was the first time we showed our
faces on camera in the vlog to that
video yes and after we made our video I
went to a bunch of other videos about
anime North video just look at anime
doors 2016 or something search and I saw
max video called post con depression
blues or post kind of prescient song
yeah and I saw it and it was so funny
guys it was so funny I was like I need
to be friends with this dude that I like
message I commented like bro yes yes and
then he replied and that's how we got
started started talking on Twitter and
stuff and yeah that's how we met Mac and
black criticai a black Critic guy it was
all Brinn
Brinn introduced me to black Krynica she
said Tony said he wants to be on Rand
cafe he says it sounds like the thing
for him and I was like oh [ __ ] because
we knew Tony right he told him yes so we
see like for years Tony is a veteran
he's been around for a long time so even
like four years ago you know what we
were not as into anime as we are now we
saw black credit guy videos and his old
channel too so this was big deal Luna
Luna asks what is your guys thoughts on
people getting bullied in harassed or
liking anime Gulen I think people that
are bullying people for like a mere
doing society of service so obviously
it's it's [ __ ] like people should
not like what I like especially
something as awesome as anime that's
usually not recognized and we go into
this so much and like we should do a
whole video about how people just assume
it's for children people assume it's
cartoons right that it's not serious
that's not for adults and that's all
makes no sense
right and it's ridiculous that people
actually would try to knock someone down
a peg and make fun of over liking anime
something so good something better and
sometimes more complex and definitely
usually more complex than like Hollywood
movies and yet you're making fun of
someone for liking it like it makes
awesome another one from wound up if you
guys could cosplay or something
what would you cosplay as that isn't
code geass and I would have to say
for me it would be Okabe from steins
gate one of my favorite anime the also
cool finish it somebody okay yeah that's
the classic choice for this tall skinny
dude whoo oh my god evaporate whoa for
me I don't know because I feel like most
anime characters don't have a cool beard
like me like I think everyone would
agree to that right so I don't know I
don't know what cosplay as uh maybe when
I grow my hair out longer I can be a von
Hohenheim from full documents
Brotherhood actually laid out circular
glasses long hair also good on Marco
says comentario in Espanola Tanaka upon
si where is the barrio good well done
sir it means a wild Spanish comment
appears that's good Sanada says who is
more part with the ladies
Anna macrocosm nada I think the answer
to that is obvious I think it's pretty
obvious that Nico pardhu asks why are
y'all jobs in real life with the job do
you live in the u.s. no we actually live
in Canada on mega will you participate
in upcoming discord karaoke sessions you
know what Erik toys participating ought
to make an appearance I apologize in
advance
oh he's gonna do it he's gonna do it
stay tuned stay tuned
Renee M right congrats on reaching over
9000 subscribers guys you rock
yes we do thank you my question for you
guys is without anime in your life what
would you see yourself doing and how
different would your life be alright you
go first
okay that is really cool because yeah
from my most of my life I've been in
academia I finished a PhD and that is
cool like I studied stuff that I like
political science political philosophy
but it can be kind of dry at times
especially when you have to you guys
know how school is they give you
assignment they give you tests they give
you essays to do and usually they tell
you why you have to write about what I
love about anime is there such it's such
a diverse genres you watch any type of
anime you feel like comment
your sci-fi or philosophical or
completely just Hawaii something right
so animate was always a way for me to
escape the kind of structure of academia
so I feel like without anime I would
definitely be a much more boring person
I would not have that escape I would not
have that creativity and I would have to
be like you know like look like a
professor and [ __ ] like in a suit all
the time I feel like anime makes me more
free a free spirit Yanomami Animax bro
okay and it did it make a livin - for me
um it would be definitely I still be
into literature right now I'm doing a
finished undergraduate English language
and literature and now I'm going to
actually be doing a masters in the next
year and I love the idea of going abroad
and teaching English I love literature
right it's like anime and inspired a lot
of anime so there's very similar to
animate so of course I still love
literature but if there was no anime I
definitely find my kind of purpose for
being in literature I think you know
you'd be a bum on the street shot off
demon wolf out those ask anything here
we go what is your quest what is your
favorite color
and what is airspeed velocity of an
unladen swallow you can you can handle
an IV on a classroom not one in our
class our quest is to do dope [ __ ] at
the make animated videos yeah we our
life is so but we do dope [ __ ] well also
justice I want justice
what is your favorite color purple I go
with the red and what is the airspeed
velocity of an unladen swallow I don't
think they have to know that is anime
youtubers I think we're oh yeah we're
not physics you learning styles for
example yeah purple and blue a close
second you know what's been fun if we
actually like actually figured out the
answer for two lasers so yeah yeah I
guess I'll write it in the comment
vector Maximus asks what are your
favorite games favorite games I have to
go with Mario games actually yes you
know what we love playing mario party
mario kart we're done we played the
Gamecube one most so we have the n64
ones we played the old yeah the retro
classic mario nintendo star super slash
bro you love all well super smash bros
melee we just love love the tango games
we love them I love Counter Strike 2 but
Mario's where it's at we want those
games yeah those are the types of games
we play with our friends when they come
over like 4 players all night just
all-nighters at the alias' day
turnaround party melon all-nighters 50
dirt Mario Party those who know know how
we roll
that's right Zak man asks how many subs
do you think you can get and also we
didn't find it later but I believe Mr Al
card rules asked something similar he
said did I saw it before but then it got
lost in the comments somewhere but he
said did we ever think that we would
become so popular on YouTube as we are
now so I feel like that's a related
question goes that what do you think so
it happened quicker than I thought it
would but yes definitely I always
thought we had the potential I mean
we're humble definitely but you know
what man let's go for a let's go for a
spectacular sideways eight man let's go
for its infinite potential let's just
see how far we can take this you want to
go for that
Animax made college guy is the limit man
sky is the limit but yes our current
milestone I want to see this guy at a
maid outfit but yeah in terms of did we
ever think we would get this popular
it's like I never thought about it that
way because we just don't know just work
day to day yeah and like if you I didn't
I wanted to create a great community of
people like we have now with you guys
asking us questions and us responding
and interacting on this score on our
videos that's what we wanted and I
didn't know you know going into we
didn't know if it would take 1000
subscribers to get that or 10,000 or a
hundred thousand we just had no idea but
right now we're already there and we've
been there for a while and that's so
amazing so while we of course hope that
the community will continue to grow we
really appreciate your fight for what we
have right now
you guys are awesome we have so much fun
just interacting with you and I know you
guys do as well interact with us and
that's all we could ever ask for and
that's what I think is our goal
not necessarily popularity but just
community and just being able to do this
right sharing our passion for anime with
you guys in the world so we're here on
axe where do you see your YouTube
channel in once a two years and what's
your biggest fear for code geass
season 3 so for Cody I see the 3 my
biggest fear is Lelouch acts Suzaku my
big night that's never gonna happen
my biggest fear is jino X : because I
fear that it is possible guys I feel it
as possible and that scares me that
scares them a fan that I don't want that
II like no and where do you guys see
your YouTube channel at 1 to 2 years
everywhere yes I know but literally if
we could be you know living off of it
and once the two tiers that would be
amazing
so that would be cool or will be bummed
on the street yeah what are the other
bunny doll on those we dare shot we did
what we love let's go hashtag bum on the
street zero rights it's over 9000 with
an S at the end he says keep up that
good work your majesty still waiting for
the face you real at 1 million subs and
let's not forget hashtag rant
main cafe and hashtag Animax ASMR that
is right and 1 million subs I will do a
face reveal guys and I will do that made
[ __ ] and next question is from Julia
what's up Julia where are you guys from
Serbia you know we're from Serbia we
currently live in Ontario Canada but we
are from Serbia representing the whole
moon and would you like to live in Japan
yes definitely I'm glad so Anastos we
would definitely won another train I
think the plan is for us to spend some
time in Japan and after my master's I
was thinking going to teach English over
there so you might see some cool vlogs
in the future from Japan alright and now
a question from sung-hoon Zhang sorry
for the miss pross station if I did I
probably didn't know because I'm awesome
will you make other videos besides am I
related in the future and I want to say
that that is definitely in the plans for
this summer will definitely do start up
another channel
that has different cost because there's
just so much that we both love and
passions that we have there aren't anime
as well like literature like floss you
like just vlogs in general I have
nothing to do with the anime so I feel
like definitely there will be a space
for that now this will be our main our
main Play Store you can find us anime
uproar but I definitely would like to
create a freedom of having another
channel next question is by Ryan foo
oh right boom and not spot boy oh yeah I
got a golden fan blaster I'm going on
rise oh my boy question what was the
first anime you guys watched it was your
favorite anime of all time so we send an
email all 5 class or story whatever it
is is who cares anyways so the first day
we watched great question because that's
what got the ball rolling for us so I'm
going to say not counting like poke
wandering boldly because like yeah
that's the family and we know everyone
say oh yeah the real thing that really
like sparked my interest that made me
realized was something as anime was
actually Inuyasha it was so dark
compared to these other anime that we
were watch like Pokemon stuff then I
come home after school it was at night
and I look forward to watching yah show
or just like a different world view of
Japan and I'm like man this is very cool
so that was actually the first anime not
super mainstream although it's become
mainstream now that I watched and I
thought man I want to see more of it
yeah for me I of course watched Dragon
Ball Z pokemon digimon older house stuff
and I did in the 9th back in the 90s
watch vision of escaflowne
when it was on TV and I really liked it
I thought it was great plot and that's a
non mainstream anime but I didn't really
classify anime as being a big thing for
adults
until I saw Death Note and when I saw
Death Note I was like men
anime is not for kids this [ __ ] is
amazing and that's what got me hooked
and it was this guy's to admit that got
me to watch Death Note of the first
place so I have to sing him for it I
guess also guys as you know it's a
thumbnail we got to thank our boy so
long guys soul maka provided this
thumbnail of me the code geass pimp but
he says that you will give something for
anima of for gold and in the future
you'll do something cool
for him but yeah so thank you bro I'm
just wondering how big the frame it
needs to be for me to put that above my
bed yeah amazing work bro I'm ready yeah
and we're going to link in the
description to soul Monica's patreon
where you can help them out and you know
check out his art he takes commissions
if you want to arm I got warning he does
do make Lutz slash anti art so you know
if you click there it might be warned it
might be 18 plus so you are you've been
warned however so Marcus thanks a lot
man you know how much I appreciate this
you know how much I appreciate this man
thanks Roz you were all so maka thank
you we can't thank you enough man
especially me I especially can't thank
you enough and for the last question I
remember seeing this one but again it
disappeared somewhere two comments I
think not I might have asked it but if
not let me know in the comments who did
it was who would win in a fight between
Anna Mac and golden and obviously made
that obviously really obviously me
everybody know what you [ __ ] watch no
no oh my god oh that's the wrong code up
here oh my god tell Esther yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]